هذا احد المعسكرات التابعه للجيش
الاسرائيلي والمقام تماما على الحدود
المصريه
وعلى بعد بضعه كيلومترات قليله فقط في هذا
الشارع الامني المخصص فقط للمركبات
العسكريه وقعت عمليه التسلل التي نفذها
الجندي المصري وقتل خلالها ثلاثه جنود
اسرائيليين في اعقاب هذه العمليه فتح
الجيش الاسرائيلي
تحقيقات واسعه للوقوف على ملابسات هذه
العمليه على ملابسات هذا
الحادث الذي يوصف في اسرائيل بانه
اخفاق وفشل امني كبير لاسيما وان الجندي
المصري تمكن من الدخول عبر هذا السياج
الامني
المزود بتقنيات عاليه
المنظومه كاميرات مراقبه متطوره جدا
ومجاسات استشعار ترصد اي حركه على هذا
السياج الحدودي لكن مع ذلك تمكن هذا
الجندي من الدخول وايضا من البقاء لعده
ساعات حتى تم اكتشاف
امره في اعقاب هذه العمليه ايضا كان من
الملاحظ ان
الجانب الاسرائيلي يرفض الروايه المصريه
التي تتحدث عن ان هذا الجندي كان يلاحق
مهربين مخدرات
ورغم ان هذا الحدث يوصف بانه خطير جدا من
قبل المسؤولين السياسيين والعسكريين من
بينهم بطبيعه الحال رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو الا ان هناك محاوله واضحه من قبل
المسؤولين الاسرائيليين في احتواء هذا
الحدث وعدم التصعيد تجنبا للاضرار
بالعلاقات مع مصر وتجنبا لاي ربما تداعيات
على المستوى الامني او السياسي مع مصر
نجمان سمري الجزيره من الحدود المصريه